what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are wrapping up Craven's last hunt in
time for Spider-Man 2 on the PS5 and as
always at the end of this video you'll
find a link to the playlist with the
other two videos to get you caught up on
everything that's going on but in effect
video number one was Craven killing
Spider-Man video number two was Craven
replacing Spider-Man video number three
is Spider-Man coming back from the dead
now here's the crazy thing about this
right a lot of what goes on in Craven's
last Hunt is as much metaphorical and
met textual as it is tangible which is
to say Peter Parker is alive and you're
actually going to find that a good chunk
of time is past since he was shot in the
chest by Craven but it's a really cool
moment here because it kind of has this
sort of inner monologue where he's
basically dealing with the ramifications
of when Craven killed him because
something to understand is that Craven
going after Spider-Man happened like
that literally Spider-Man's just in New
York and then suddenly Craven's like
chasing him down all over the place and
thenot shoots him in the chest point
blank with a rifle so it really kind of
took him by surprise and it was an
incredibly traumatic experience and so
because of that he kind of jumps back
and forth between his love for Mary Jane
Watson and basically succumbing to his
injuries and the just psychological
effect of it right basically life and
death and so because of this while he
does talk about Mary Jane that's his
anchor to life that's the thing that
brings him back the other part of this
is reminiscing and kind of thinking
about everything Craven told him because
one of the things to know during this
story Craven the hunter had kind of
stopped believing that Spider-Man was
just a guy out there who has powers and
instead he started to see him as more of
like a mythological being right a person
out there that just represents power and
so on and so forth almost magical in
nature and so by taking out Spider-Man
it was kind of like Craven solidifying
himself as the greatest hunter to ever
live which is actually a pretty accurate
description just because of the fact
that with his Spider Sense Spider-Man
can take on most anybody out there
outside of just incredibly powerful
reality warpers right but like a really
good example of this in Avengers versus
X-men he basically overpowered Colossus
who was also the Juggernaut at the same
time right that's the power of the
spider sense guys but ultimately he ends
up digging himself out of the grave and
coming back now for those of you guys
who were curious about the dark costume
this of course Rose to prominence
because of the design of his costume
around the middle of Secret Wars we
ended up finding out it was a Venom
symbiot later on down the line but it
pops in and out in Marvel Comics from
time to time because fans just love to
see it but once he comes out what he
realizes is that by going through and
just looking at like newspaper clippings
and so on actually making his way
through the Craven of estate right like
craving the Hunter's home he realized
he's been dead for two weeks or at least
been out of it for two weeks now the
reality here is that he survived because
of his healing Factor right like
Spider-Man has a healing Factor it
doesn't get talked to about a whole lot
it's nowhere near the level of like
Deadpool Wolverine The Incredible Hulk
but it is capable and depending on the
severity of the injury he can heal and
then come back which is exactly what
happened here but it took two weeks for
him to recover and then basically emerge
now the thing about this and what's so
cool is that you get to see Spider-Man
as you normally never see him this dude
is incensed and rarely do you ever get
to see that right it's one of the
coolest things when you get to see a
pissed off Spider-Man oh it's amazing
like for example in uh God what was it
renew your valves when he let Venom die
just like stuff like that right you get
to just see these amazing moments where
Spider-Man is just eight kinds of pissed
off and in this instance he goes after
these two henchmen who were here beats
the living tar out of them and is like
where's Craven where is this guy and
ultimately he ends up finding out that
Craven is in New York and Craven himself
is just kind of like Spider-Man's coming
he's going to return and he's actually
sort of looking forward to the moment
when Spider-Man comes back now before he
does he of course stops off to see Mary
Jane Watson one because she's the love
of his life and two because the guy's
basically gone two weeks without getting
laid I mean what would you do in that
circumstance right so of course he ends
up getting with Mary Jane Watson the two
touch nutty bits and then he goes
forward from there but in all
seriousness right I mean all joking
aside the thing about this is that him
getting with Mary Jane isn't necessarily
just to you know satisfy some crimeal
urges it's really more of him trying to
find some measure of normaly right to
feel like the world didn't end and Mary
Jane Watson kind of being his foundation
right the person that grounds him that
reminds him that no matter what happens
as long as she's there everything's fine
he can't get over Craven it's just a
ghost that lingers in the back of his
head Craven got the better of Spider-Man
Craven killed Spider-Man then Craven
replaced Spider-Man he stole his life
and so because of this he goes after
Craven now of course when he catches up
to him the fight between the two is
really really interesting because
Spider-Man just pummels this guy and
Craven does nothing right he actually
gives us this amazing monologue right he
says and yet within him is something
more something great something awful the
essence of the demon that brought Russia
to ruin the demon that destroyed my
father consumed my mother the demon I
have at long last defeated now this is
kind of like the metaphorical part right
Spider-Man didn't destroy
Russia right it was really just more of
like the collapse of the Soviet Union
and the demon representing in a lot of
ways the concept of change right the
death of something and The Rebirth of
something else but Craven is kind of
reminiscent of like the old days right
the old country the Soviet Union Russia
at the height of its power depending on
who you're talking to but he says yes
yes I hear you I understand it's almost
time but not yet not yet not till my
victory is complete and it will only be
complete when he understands but he
doesn't understand and that's why he
tells him right where he just puts his
hands up and just let Spider-Man
absolutely beat the crap out of him he's
like I'm not going to resist I have no
reason to fight and he says don't you
see I finally won I killed you
Spider-Man I buried you and after I
killed you I took your place it's the
ultimate accomplishment it's the
ultimate achievement what better way to
defeat your opponent than to not only
quote unquote kill them but then take
everything of value from them right and
that's the thing he says you have to go
forward for the rest of your life
knowing I got the better of you I
overpowered you I took you out I am your
Superior in every sense of the way you
can lie to yourself you can tell
yourself whatever it is that you want to
say but I am better than you you know it
and I know it and so he says follow me
and that's the crazy thing is Spider-Man
does just because of the fact that a
Spider Sense will tell him if there's
any kind of danger there's no spider
sense going off so there's no reason to
believe there's an actual trap and what
he does is he takes him down to meet a
character by the name of verman which
Spider-Man's already aware of now this
is an aspect of the story that we hadn't
necessarily covered and Truth to tell it
was because it just made more sense to
wait until this moment to do it but
verman had basically been attacking
people during the time when Spider-Man
was Spider-Man but also when Craven was
Spider-Man Actually attacking and
consuming people and in fact he ended up
earning the name the cannibal killer but
what had gone on here is that Craven had
basically defeated and subdued Vermin
now one part of this is because of the
fact that it's Craven right he's always
on for the greatest hunt right tracking
down the greatest possible prey that he
can but the other part of this is he saw
Vermin as a part of a plan that with him
disguised as Spider-Man he was basically
torturing Vermin right like burning him
different things like that and basically
convincing Vermin that like Spider-Man
was a bad guy Spider-Man was the one
that was harming him and so that's why
when he walks towards him with the torch
it's really more the torch he focuses on
than Craven himself because it terrifies
him right it's actually pretty sad and
it's a pretty terrible thing but every
time he tries to reach for the cage to
get out the electrified cage
electrocutes him right and so it's just
one of these things where he's just
constantly tormented and in seeing this
Spider-Man attacks Craven exactly the
way that you would expect him to right
he goes after that guy and again where
Craven just kind of makes fun of him he
just sort of pokes at him a little bit
right saying things like before I found
the honor and dignity I'd lost when my
country my parents fell to the spider
and the Primitive Wilds of Africa hear
me Spider-Man hear me hear the Bellow of
the elephant the Roar of the lion the
Triumph of Craven he's relishing in all
of it right he's relishing in the fact
that he was able to push Spider-Man to
the edge he's relishing in the fact that
Spider-Man is so pissed off he's
relishing in everything that's that's
happened right killing him taking his
place the whole nine yards and and in
fact he even kind of shows a moment of
affection Right like he's like it
saddens me to see you this way
Spider-Man right it saddens me to see
you so angry right and he says in some
strange inexplicable way it saddens me
to see you so upset right to like touch
him to see Spider-Man recoil it's one of
those things where depending on who you
talk to some people will say that the
relationship between Craven and
Spider-Man is not that dissimilar from
the relationship between like the Joker
and Batman in the sense that there are
people who argue that Joker's in love
with Batman and that's why he chases him
right he goes after him playing the
whole cat- and mouse game right people
look at Craven and Spider-Man and very
much see the same thing based on this
story it's one of the big benefits of
Craven's last Hunt is that is a story
that's very much up to interpretation in
terms of what his actual motivations are
what he means when he says things and so
on and so forth It's why the story stood
the test of Taun and so what he does is
he basically unlocks the cage where
Vermin is and then Vermin goes after
spider- and it's really kind of by way
of crav and goating him and saying like
Spider-Man's the one that's harmed you
right Spider-Man the one that's
tormented you right don't let him get
away with it don't let him think that
he's better stronger than you are right
hurt him back verman you owe it to
yourself to all of us right and Vermin
immediately attacks Spider-Man now one
of the cool things here is that Vermin
starts to get the upper hand right now
some of it's because Spider-Man's kind
of holding back to a degree he doesn't
really want to harm the guy but at the
same time even when he's trying to
reason with Vermin and saying like I'm
not the guy who harmed you that was
Craven Vermin doesn't care and in fact
Vermin doesn't even believe him and so
Vermin starts to get the upper hand
slashing him scratching him and
potentially could have even killed
Spider-Man and the thing about this is
that Craven watches it all go down he
watches it all happen and then he says
how old I suddenly feel how unutterably
tired the game was a good one man to
spider spider to man but it was so very
long they said my mother was insane
right he's just kind of watching this
whole thing happen and as verman starts
to get the upper hand and is actually
about to kill Spider-Man Craven's like
no right breaks out his whip throws a
dagger in in vermin's hand sticks it to
a wall and it's like your Point's been
made your work here's done right and
just sends him out he says go be free
and the thing about this is he tells
Spider-Man you got to get out of here
right like let me help you up you're
free to leave I know you're not going to
let somebody like verman just run a muck
out there in the city of New York you're
going to go find him but but the reality
here is that he's done he has no reason
to hunt anymore and in fact that's what
he tells Spider-Man right when
Spider-Man doesn't necessarily believe
him right he's just like why would you
just let me leave and his response is
after all these years you surely know
that I'm a man of my word and I give you
my word from this night forward Craven
the hunter will never hunt again and
what he says is Spider-Man says I'll be
back right and Craven says I don't doubt
it this this is a really important part
he says I don't doubt it every man every
woman Every Nation every age has its
spider you have to be mine what a burden
what an honor and he says goodbye so a
Spider-Man takes off Craven officially
ends his hunt right he says how calm I
feel how peaceful as if something inside
me some knot some tangle of fear and
anger and so much more has finally been
untied all these years fleeing Russia
suffocating in America finding release
finding honor in the jungle all these
years and I've never known peace or calm
or that elusive thing called Happiness
but I feel as if I can know it now that
it's nearby just outside perhaps hidden
in the patter of the rain the drum beat
of the Thunder peace calm happiness an
ending now he picks up a rifle and
that's the end of Craven right he
literally just ends himself just like
that and like that's how the story ends
that's how Craven dies right like Craven
die this this story Craven's last hunt
it's the death of Craven the hunter
right it's one of the coolest things of
course Spider-Man catches up to Vermin
and Vermin gets thrown in jail and Yad y
y but this is the reason why Craven's
last Hunt is so significant it's the
official death of his character in
Marvel continuity but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end make sure you guys check this
playlist if you want to get caught up
with the rest of the story let me know
what you think of it down in the
comments and I will catch you all later
peace